[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and in this video we're gonna
answer one of your questions is coffee
really unhealthy for you now you guys
know that I love coffee but to make this
bit more interesting I brought in a
coffee expert I brought in to thank you
guys for having me it's a great
privilege to be on the show hope I can
inform you guys as much as possible and
keep this interesting no he's a very
humble guy so he won't really talk about
his expertise but we're actually sitting
here at his coffee shop that's why it
might be a little bit noisy here so just
yeah sorry for that okay with us yeah so
let's not waste any more time let's get
right into the video mistakes make you
strong all right now you guys know that
I love coffee because on most of my
videos I started off with a cup of
coffee now coffee
I know coffee can be really healthy for
you good free but it can also be very
bad for you depends on how you drink
right so let's talk about weight loss
first
[Music]
so to you can you lose weight with
coffee
well a simplistic very straight answer
moderation is the key guys if you eat
too much like eat in moderation training
moderation you can't lay on the couch
expecting to drink 5 cups of coffee and
it's gonna help you to lose weight now
now can coffee house yes definitely
coffee especially espressos is an
appetite suppressant so it does take
away your hunger in Saudi Arabia they
used to call or they call coffee kava
and you get kawaii when you drink it now
if I translate that is basically to lose
your appetite yeah so coffee is
definitely an appetite suppressant as
well as a tab ilysm booster so when you
drink a cup of coffee especially
suppressors it basically pushes up your
blood pressure so it gets the oxygen and
the blood flowing through the system so
when you go training it helps you to
lose weight a lot faster and because
oxygen is moving through your system a
lot quicker it actually repairs the
muscles that you tear a lot fast with
the proteins I didn't know that Wow
yeah so yes it can definitely help lose
weight but again moderation is the key
ok so it is good for weight loss right
it can help you right so next
you guys asked about the hair so too is
it healthy for your hair it definitely
is if you go to your local shop they
will sell a shampoo bottle with caffeine
inside the reason is why the caffeine
molecule goes down to the hair follicle
and actually stimulates the hair growth
okay but it is better to prevent hair
loss so it works for hair growth but
it's better for hair loss so if you
struggling with hair loss go get a
bottle it's good for stimulating the
hair follicles hmm wow thank you for
that there's a lot of guys actually that
asked me that question I made a video
about that but I didn't even include the
coffee but I should have right okay
anyway let's move on to the heart is it
good for your heart
definitely when caffeine enters the
heart or when caffeine enters the body
it has an effect on this I call it the
stimulant of the protein molecules
inside the body cells ya know I'm not a
scientist so I don't know what that
means but I do understand that because
of that the high flow of blood it
actually prevents certain heart diseases
and also can fork um heart attacks whoa
because blood is flowing a lot faster it
is very hard for cholesterol to then
actually get stuck inside your veins so
is it good for your heart definitely if
you're a trainer even better before you
gotta gen-pop a double shot espresso get
that blood pressure really high that
gets the oxygen flowing really fast and
then you heal a lot faster right so it
is definitely good for the heart
what if you have high blood pressure now
that is very important very great
question here if you struggle with high
blood pressure
stay away try and take only about one a
day just off to you wake up because then
your blood flows obviously a lot slower
because you were sleeping so we'll get
you awake but if you struggle with high
blood pressure do you go and see your
doctor ask him how much you can intake
because it pushes you up your blood
pressure quite a lot so that also means
if you have low blood pressure is really
good for you it's really good for you
because it gets the blood pumping it
gets you active to get your energy
levels up and get you very focused now
an interesting thing about coffee or
caffeine is that caffeine can actually
not create energy okay
which is a huge myth because we were
taught growing up and I've got to gives
you a lot of energy yeah but it's more
the blood flow of oxygen going through
your system that gives you energy are I
now an interesting fact of caffeine of
course is it is an antioxidant yeah it's
good to detox and it's got inflammatory
properties so if you have information in
your system it also helps obviously to
get rid of most amount that's that's
pretty good I think a lot of people
don't know that
[Music]
the other thing that asked is for your
brain is coffee good for your brain
definitely yeah like it is so good for
your brain
caffeine has three effects on the human
body it relaxes you okay it gives you
very good focus and it gives you
phenomenal concentration so therefore
when you drink coffee you can sit and
concentrate for a very long period now
when you add sugar to it sugar obviously
being an energizing substance and
caffeine being a very steroid type of
substance it focuses the energy inside
the sugar so they forgives your sugar
rush okay now caffeine just by itself
very good for concentration the way that
caffeine actually affects the brain
mostly is caffeine kind of tricks the
brain into thinking that you're not
tired so the brain has these smaller
receptors we call them at Danis scene
receptors okay as you go through your
normal day your body creates adenosine
through the rung of the day certify at
the end of the day your body goes oh
they're then seen as full so therefore
you need to be tired now when you take
it in a C molecule and you take a
caffeine molecule and you put them on
top of each other they look very very
similar alright so the brain doesn't
know the difference between the two so
now when you drink a cup of coffee that
the caffeine actually goes and lies
inside there then the same receptor
which means your brain doesn't know that
you get inquired even though you are so
that's why you can work for so many
hours on end without getting tired at
all all right now the unhealthy thing of
that of course is sleeping less yeah now
your body's reaction to being tired is
make you sick give you food get you in
bed so you can recover yeah so too much
caffeine there yes okay
I've had a lot of people say hey it's
very bad for your liver so is it too
much again moderation moderation is the
key now they say that you can't have a
bad effect on your levin unit and your
kidneys unless you don't drink any water
now of course coffee being an
antioxidant if you flush your system too
much with an antioxidant it dries out so
therefore bad chemicals get stuck in the
liver and the kidneys and then creates
kidney stones and you don't want that
none so too much caffeine is not bad but
too little water with caffeine oh that's
a nation doctor just make sure you drink
a lot of water all right
[Music]
and maybe you can just explain a little
bit is there's a difference between
instant coffee and ground coffee awesome
maybe you can explain a bit of that ok
so now he's really hitting one of my
interesting nerves yeah so you get two
types of coffee beans in the world to
get robusta beans and you get a rabbit
come in okay now robusta beans have
round about 2.6 milligrams of caffeine
for a hundred mils of your drink
yeah Arabica coffee has 0.6 correct
milligrams of caffeine per 100 more that
you drink so rabbika being the more
healthier coffee so if you're gonna
drink or consume 20 cups a day take
Arabica is way better for you now the
way that they make instant coffees dies
instant coffees originally was coffee
beans it's not a different type of
coffee yeah it's just a process to make
it more convenient for you to make it
hurt so the way that they make instant
coffee is they grind down a whole lot of
robusta beans they brew it for 48 hours
they blow it through these pipes they
freeze it with liquid nitrogen then they
take the liquid nitrogen into and you
mattified ovens they take that the
humidity out the water content up and it
turns into a powder so therefore you've
got no coffee left inside your cup when
you add water afterwards so it was
coffee it's not less coffee now if you
enjoy instant coffee enjoy it it's
nothing wrong with it your palate your
mouth who are we to say what you need to
like in this line they're very important
but when it comes to the healthy
benefits of it Arabica is better why
less caffeine and not less effect from
your body
and you can consume a lot more before it
has the same effect on the key bees and
the liver as to compare to robust times
yes sir
rather consume Arabica now arabica
obvious not throw this word out what is
that coffee originally is a coffee
cheering the put inside the cherry is a
coffee bean we take the bean we roast it
then it expands to about 60 to 65% in
size now once it gets there you get the
robusta and Arabica robusta very hard
very stubborn bean we have to full roast
it which means it becomes very bitter
that's why it's used for instant coffees
it's cheaper as well our radical beans
we can do light roasts which brings
these flute fruity flavors and cocoa
flavors the tobacco flavors into your
palate 9 which is gorgeous gorgeous
coffee all right I feel like that is
real cop
I have a question though right so how
much is too much coffee too much coffee
now that question comes up a lot so too
much coffee I think doesn't exist
too much caffeine 400 milligrams
according to doctors is where you push
your limit too high so 400 milligrams of
caffeine now guys when it comes to
coffee you can consume quite a bit back
that's like between fifty and a hundred
cups of coffee that's a lot I don't
think any stomach can take that amount
of coffee so don't stress about too many
cups of coffee I've consumed between 15
and 20 espressos a day so don't stress
about how much coffee you drink just
make sure you drink enough water okay
water is again the moderation but if you
drink enough water they won't be spiced
for too much coffee yeah basically yeah
that would be better for your kidney
alright last question there's a lot of
people that drink coffee with sugar so
maybe you could just explain to them
what does that do exactly okay sugar
first of all sugar is really bad for you
they say statistically the biggest cause
of cancer in the world but that let's
put that aside why do we add sugar to
our coffee because we grew up on instant
coffees or better coffee yeah now the
reason why you add sugar to coffee is to
break down the bitter flavor
nobody likes something better so again
moderation is key add just enough sugar
to break the bitterness so you can
actually still enjoy the cup but when
you drink Arabica coffee guys there's so
much flavor in the coffee yeah what you
can taste grapes apples strawberries
raspberries caramel Coco's why would you
want to destroy that beautiful flavor by
adding sugar to it now you guys know how
to drink coffee the right way and it's
not unhealthy it's actually good for you
now if you're curious about what coffee
tastes really good we're gonna add our
favorite coffees for you in the video
description down below so you can check
that out also check out theories Channel
we're gonna do another collaboration
where we're gonna do some coffee tasting
these guys really want to check that out
I'm gonna add it for you here and I'm
gonna introduce his palate to some
beautiful coffees that he would like and
then if there's any requests from you
guys more that you want to know about
coffee we more than love to make the
content for you because at the end of
the day it's about you and not about us
that's it that's right and if you liked
the video give us a thumbs up subscribe
and we'll see in the next video
Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]